welcome to this video playing grope and
displaying the grope of course yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay I could play this
wacky gambit here okay let's play the
wacky gambit it's supposed to be very
good for black but it's of course the
total total mess that play us like that
wand okay how to do it yeah 9s six maybe
just develop stuff I really hate that
this Bishop is I mean it's not hanging
but I can't let's develop maybe takes 24
something like that I don't know if
taking us is a good idea ever
there's nobody 6g can't Bishop c5 I
don't know I really don't know him yeah
this is the thing that might might be
good but it's exactly the kind of
position that this is this kind of
player wants like complete completely
insane stuff but okay merits blitz chess
what not so important um okay I think
they have to after we move that
ultimately
yeah I really think that this is
compensation some somehow but I will
mess really
I'll just go to create next pretty much
whatever he does well I'm not sure okay
let's take the b-pawn get root before so
in the mix so yeah it's always somehow
intended to take maybe not g4 is over
here
that's an interesting was shooting for
93
or on f2 yeah that's a pretty good move
actually
Castle so long we have a very nice
choice tonight f2 Bishop III check all
looks good
pretty nice okay this one
and now this is actually nobody for
night is hanging okay
I can play 93 so yeah I'm always to
teach a comp but it doesn't look right
somehow but my bishop is hanging also
we might move the Queen actually okay
it's not a big deal
still a completely murky position
I guess it will still take it on you
three even though that bishop is
exceptionally strong 23 that's 95 just
went back yeah I wanted to check even
though this is not fantastico anything
chant like him
let's check King f2 I've got 94 check
but I don't know if it is any any good
night at five also might be good yeah I
guess I need to increase my speed
be sure to be six I want to put it there
it's a really good square
okay I'm looking to be file that's not
great but please NIDA for things like
that it's not not on anymore the e-file
takes takes this and stuff one here okay
taking is looking bad it's not a good
idea
95 that would throw more it would be
very come on let's do it looking I have
three here
time warning
and it's it's very dangerous for white
this position but it's also difficult 96
don't know 93 impossible it's impossible
impossible to calculate him and happy
should be three of course okay then you
have knowledge for knowledge voice yeah
still on
and h3 is hanging that that actually
collects some material I will take I
will take the the night and just take
the night here no this this is a very
awkward pin
that should be pretty good
okay Jess ridden the Queen check check
check check
checkmate okay that was a wide riot yeah
you know if you can get G flow played
against you it's yeah it will be really
something crazy yeah as I said this is
believed to be good for black here this
this whole thing but yeah it's just it
just totally crazy total craziness
looking at this with a computer is
probably very I know I'm like a word
there it probably it's a real reality
show key I want what actually was
happening computer things I'm clearly
better here Bishop f5 was interesting
here no I never considered this always
look sad weird because of this but it
seems that this is just good hmm that
looks pretty good
okay I played this check I'm actually
reasonably happy if I didn't blunder the
house here position is so complicated
actually better here according to the
engine funny and if five was also
correct nice and now Quincy a it was
winning Wow
92 also but this also wins now f6 I went
here now the computer gives I mean it
gives black a win but it says that this
is the relatively best move I can take
chat chick here and repeat 5 Wow check
nice chat here this is this is actually
winning right to be 8 yeah she was happy
to win the Queen and a couple of seconds
up on the clock so that worked out
alright yeah this line is quite funny
against the group but really be aware
that many players who will go for this
is white will actually cherish this
total craziness yeah so it's something
to be aware off and some say no option
might be a better choice sometimes in a
practical game okay well thanks for
watching